sea of thieves is often at its best
when it turns into total chaos imagine
sinking a ship
manned by skeletons or diving into a
sunken wreck loading your brig up with
all the loot you find
suddenly a huge galleon manned by four
players appears from behind an island
intent on stealing the booty you just
got done stealing
the galleon turns its broadside cannons
in your direction
for a sneak attack returning fire
repairing your ship and desperately
turning your sails to make an escape or
firing a crewmate over to the enemy to
lay waste to them and steal their stuff
are the moments that make rare's pirate
adventure live game
so memorable
but even though a lot of sea of thieves
fun comes from
unpredictable interactions with other
players developer rare has also created
some involved
intelligent story content for the game
as well called tall
tales with its new expansion a pirate's
life rare adds five tall tales to sea of
thieves that tie in with disney's
pirates of the caribbean film franchise
a pirate's life adds a lot to sea of
thieves
with new elements for its open world
sandbox and several
hours of story content it's deep enough
for experienced pirates to enjoy
but approachable enough for newbies
excited to sail the seas
with captain jack sparrow though the
expansion is occasionally held back by
bugs and relies on some of sea of
thieves weaker elements
like unreliable platforming the
expansion is still a great excuse to try
your hand
or hook at the pirate's life the core of
the expansion are the five new
tall tales which have you meeting up
with pirates of the caribbean mainstay
jack sparrow and his crew
scandals villains and knives streak up
me hearties
[Music]
through some kind of adventuring the
movie characters have found their way
into the weird and mystical world of the
video game but they've been chased there
by davey jones
the magical pirates of the caribbean
villain jones wants to take control of
the sea of thieves
so you need to save jack from the game's
realm of the dead figure out jones plans
and ultimately send the squid-faced
villain back to where he belongs
playing through these stories takes you
to two new locations
the sea of the damned full of puzzles
and secrets and the sunken kingdom a
colorful
underwater realm the tall tales
themselves are
pretty linear story levels but like sea
of thieves other tall tales
they do a great job of challenging you
to explore the environment
solve puzzles and navigate imaginative
areas
in the first for instance you'll need to
rescue the head of an
undead skeletal pirate captain and you
can uncover secrets throughout the area
by placing his head on skeleton bodies
so he can take control of them
of course this is a pirates of the
caribbean story so you'll spend a lot of
the duration
encountering various movie characters
jack sparrow is around the most
and thanks to some funny lines and
exciting gameplay moments
he's a pretty good addition captain jack
sparrow
though since you came here to rescue me
you probably knew that already
sparrow's presence helps meld the disney
aspects of the expansion
with sea of thieves foundation which
helps to make sure the content doesn't
feel like a digression
into another franchise he's the same
funny quirky character from the movies
but he's also pretty useful at key
moments even joining your ship's crew
for a while
he's around just enough to make this
feel like a pirates of the caribbean
story
while also working as a fitting sea of
thieves story
a pirate's life is also a useful entry
point for new players
the tall tales mostly take place off the
beaten path
or in their own instances so you're
unlikely to run into other players
who might try to steal your stuff sink
your boat or otherwise hassle you
the stakes are also pretty low anytime
you die you just respawn in the same
place in the tall tale story
without losing any progress that makes
this content pretty great for just
getting started in sea of thieves
or for lone players who want to venture
into the game without risks raised by
other pirates
the drawback is that a pirate's life
doesn't really feel
like the rest of sea of thieves it's
more of its own
separate thing in the rest of rare's
game sailing around requires constant
vigilance as you scope for ships and
other potential threats
the openness of the game and the
randomness created by other players
are what makes sea of thieves so fun and
unique
a pirate's life doesn't really include
that aspect
the stories are more straightforward and
traditional video game fare
you'll move through distinct levels on a
specific path
and while there are side puzzles and
secrets along the way
there's still only one way forward so a
pirate's life gives
a sense of sea of thieves but it's
incomplete
without other players that can be good
and bad
since a pirate's life eases you into the
water rather than shoving you off the
plank
but if you're new it can also give a
skewed perception of what the game
is the tall tales for a pirate's life
are
also a bit on the buggy side at launch
although rare has already released a
patch
to clean up some of the issues
[Music]
still when i played there were a few
game affecting oddities
like checkpoints that didn't work
falling from high places and finding
yourself stuck behind locked doors that
you'd already opened
or fights where elements didn't reset
correctly after dying
still i played through all five tall
tales alone
and didn't encounter any game breaking
issues the other upshot of a pirate's
life is the way it reinvigorates
the rest of the game the expansion
introduces a bunch of new enemies to the
game world that shake up your usual
sea of thieves adventures undersea
sirens make jumping off your boat all
the more treacherous
while on land you'll have to deal with
phantom pirates who can briefly make
themselves invisible
there are also three giant human
crustacean hybrid creatures called ocean
crawlers
an armored crab a poisonous clam and an
electric eel
all three require distinct strategies to
defeat
and they can synergize their abilities
to add additional challenge
to help you deal with these threats you
can find a new item called the trident
of dark tides
which charges up to fire a bubble of
energy
that can be devastating to ai enemies
and other players alike
for most of the life of sea of thieves
players have been facing a variety of
skeleton pirates all of which fight in
more or less the same way so throwing in
some new creatures
livens things up quite a bit and if you
can find it in the world
the trident of dark tides also creates
new strategies in combat
it all adds a little more depth to help
make the game continue to feel like it's
evolving
all the time a pirate's life is a big
fun addition to sea of thieves
that offers a lot of content both for
existing players
and fans of disney's pirates it doesn't
quite represent the best of what sea of
thieves has to offer
but this is still a great excuse to
hoist the pirate flag for the first time
and offers a new horizon to explore for
long time
[Music]
scalawags
[Music]
you